even when Republicans don't say it or  don't realize it  their actions have been disastrous for  the economy for decades now  that's just the reality trickle-down  economics where you cut taxes for the  rich to  raise the tide for all boats it doesn't  work  flat out doesn't work we've had  economists on we've looked at the data  just doesn't work and so Republicans  would never say we're going to cut taxes  on the rich to wreck the economy no they  they might even think it helps the  economy but it doesn't so the policy has  been bad for the economy for a very long  time  um Reagan exploded uh spending while  cutting taxes it's been policy for a  very long time Bush started two Wars  created the Department of Homeland  Security and TSA while giving tax cuts  to the rich  come on it's the same thing Trump added  trillions in debt while giving tax cuts  to the rich this has been what they've  done for decades